hey everybody's Jessie and I'm gonna
switch things up a little bit from what
we've been doing the last two episodes
all right so I want to work on some UI
stuff so specifically when the let me
bring it over what I've done so far just
to give you just to get you caught up a
little bit actually had I didn't have a
ton of time to do work today because I
had two phone interviews with candidates
for a web developer job and actually
went well so I'm happy about that
but it did leave me with not a lot of
time for this so what I've done since
the last four since yesterday is I Trent
change these into checkboxes and I made
it to that they they work if you check
them both you can see all both free and
paid obviously or if you uncheck them
both you can still see free and paid so
it's the sorting works I'm sorry the
filtering works this kind of works right
now this is the materialized drop-down
or select input to use this some
JavaScript it needs to be initialized
and right now I'm having trouble making
it initialize after the API call comes
back and it should populate this with
our categories so basically it's
initializing too soon and it's not
including what we need so I'm gonna
we're probably not gonna work on that
today today I'm gonna worry more about
this down here
going to change these and instead of
cards they're gonna be more like full
width sections with an image over here
and then some text with the option of
having even more text you can click and
it would expand and show more text there
so this is all based on my last meeting
with the people that I'm making the site
for and that's more of what they want
they're not really fans of this this
layout so let me check the the live chat
before we get started so say I hey
everybody I see someone asks when to use
react j/s and I'm not sure how to
pronounce that name because there's no
vowels in it well unless you count the Y
at the end so it's certainty I'm not
sure what you're asking about when to
use react j/s so if you could explain
that a little bit more I'd be happy to
answer but since there's not a lot going
on in the live chat right now yeah yeah
the theme just reminded me that Y is
indeed about it is I almost almost
forgot that for a second but I'm gonna
go ahead and just get started so I have
on a piece of paper I have a sketch of
what I want this to look like so I
haven't converted that to anything else
but so you won't be able to see what I
really wanted to look like until it
starts to take shape other than you know
my brief description of it so I'm gonna
move this over
and I think I'm a right now if you want
to follow along with the repo we're on
the branch
that's called resource sorting so I
pushed before this started I pushed
everything up to github so it should be
up to date I think I may do this UI
stuff on this branch don't know let me
know if there's any objections to that I
don't I think it'll work I'd hate to I'd
hate to start a new branch for this
since I these kind of are gonna go
together yeah I'll just do it on this
branch
okay I did have a question about the
animation I had a couple questions about
the UI so let me just do that first
since this this is all about the UI
anyway it makes sense to answer some
questions about it right off the bat so
the first question from Thomas are you
using one component for each card yes so
it's this is a component separate react
component and they're just populated
with data from the WordPress API so this
is separate component and at a question
about the animation for the checkboxes
so this this little animation here oops
I guess it doesn't work too well when i
zoom in but that animation actually is
from the materialized CSS framework and
it's it's pure CSS it doesn't take any
JavaScript or anything so if you want to
use that actually if you want to use
this animation without the entire
materialized framework if you check out
my code pen which I don't even I don't
remember what the link is to that I'll
have to I don't know maybe I'll have to
find it real quick and put it in but
basically I made a version of this that
works pretty much the same way that
doesn't use I don't it's just pure CSS
it doesn't use JavaScript you don't have
to download the whole framework so if
anybody's interested in that I will I'll
put that link in the chat in the
description let me know otherwise I'm
gonna take the time and bother with it
okay cool maybe I will find that link
hey Bill made it glad you could join us
bill
okay Thomas maybe the animation for the
card reshuffling yes so the the
animation is using a JavaScript plug-in
called masonry so this all does exist
within one component called masonry so
within that component I have all these
other components for the cards but it's
all wrapped in the one masonry component
which I get to show you that here make
this a little bigger there we go so
within so you can see this is the
masonry component everything Rhett is
wrapped in that and then the cards are
just produced within here so we had to
do something cool was I think it was
Fabien who did this pull request so I
actually had someone submit a pull
request that that perfected all of this
because I could not get it working on a
live stream the way I wanted it to
so Fabien if you I don't know if he's
joined in to the chat or not but he
could probably talk even more about how
this works well I have a lot of
questions right off the bat it was okay
so it's Anna's back hey how's it going
glad glad you're back asked are you
using git flow I'm not familiar with
what git flow is so I'm assuming that
I'm not using it
okay you guys are hearing static let me
see I'm gonna move my phone farther away
because it could be from my phone I did
have a fan on too but that's been off
for a couple of minutes so it's probably
not that if you're still hearing it
Navan says hey i'm starting out a 100
days challenge free code camp challenge
from the 10th of July 2017 how do I
start
it's vital I think for the hundred days
of code I don't don't correct me if I'm
wrong but people just start whenever
they want right you can just pick your
own personal date and then usually
people post that you know they tweet out
with the hash tag like hundred days of
code so I don't know is there somewhere
where there's like a an actual date
like an official start date for that I
don't know okay so then I explain about
git flow which I've actually never heard
of so I'm really glad that you are
taking the time to explain this to me
so it says we get flow you create small
branches for every feature and then
merge them with develop I asked you
because I have to learn it for this new
project okay yeah so okay cool I mean I
don't I guess I don't actually like
consciously use that concept of git flow
I do try to do feature branches though
but a lot of smaller features I don't
bother making a branch on so not I
wouldn't say that I'd do that exactly
okay so let me get I really love all the
action in the live chat and everybody
contributing but I don't want to
disappoint everyone who who came here
for the code and not just to hear me so
let me go you know what I am gonna start
a new branch for this because
I'm gonna like I'm gonna change a lot of
stuff in here so this is you this is
gonna be major so I'm just gonna make
another branch I'll merge them
eventually but just in case I mess
something up I want to be able to go
back to the sorting and filtering stuff
that I was working on and have that work
and not have to worry about some UI
thing delaying that so let me bring over
my I have my terminal here I'll blow it
up a bit sorry I'm a little distracted I
always play music in the background and
my headphones and just every song that's
come up since I started it I haven't
liked so it's really annoying the sorry
about that so I just want to check make
sure there's nothing on here oh wait
there's something on here I'm not sure
what I did I really thought that I had
everything
alright doesn't even show
hmm
all right so I'm not exactly sure what I
did to be able to commit so that stinks
when that happens I could do get Fred oh
I guess I fixed it great so it must have
just been a line or something that I put
in that shouldn't have been there so now
that I know that I don't have anything
left on this branch I'm gonna take this
branch exactly where it's at and copy it
into a new one so if you're making a new
branch you can do and someone was it
bill I can't remember I think it might
have been bill in a previous show told
me that you can just do get check out
and then - B and then name your branch
and get and you'll automatically go into
that branch which is awesome and save
some time and prevents you from
accidentally making changes on a the
wrong branch so let's name this actually
no I don't want to know the one that
starts with resource so let's go new new
resource you I I don't have a problem
with long branch names because you end
up never having to type them all out
anyway you can just you know tab to
autocomplete so why not have really long
names so here we go so we're on this
branch sweet new branches I just I like
to go through that sometimes for those
of you who are maybe not familiar with
git so now that we're here I'm gonna
pull this off to the side and now I can
proceed to destroy this this component
without fear because we can always just
switch back to other branch so this is
really gonna make me sad to remove this
because this is just wonderful
Fabian did an amazing job on this pull
request and if somebody else did this
pull request and I'm giving credit where
it to the wrong person I'm really
apologize for that
but I'm pretty sure with Fabian
and so I don't really need to I guess
delete this right away because this is
just a constant we're not rendering it
yet but I need to come down here and at
least start something where I want to
put this let me uh I'm gonna pull this
off to my other screen just quickly so I
can see I think I want to try to do the
new UI element right I'm gonna show you
right here basically above this section
so that these are still down there and
like we can see the new ones I'd like to
see them side-by-side and I still want
this code right there for me to refer to
easily so I'm not going to delete it yet
it's just a matter of finding where that
spot is this components way bigger than
I would normally like a component to be
okay so there's a search there's our
tabs okay and here's where yep okay
here's what we're inserting that so I
can probably put a component in here and
we'll just we'll test this out so what I
want us to look like probably so I
mentioned early I'm using the
materialized framework so I'm gonna try
to use their classes as much as possible
so we don't have to do a lot of custom
CSS and we'll see if it works and then
if we need to edit it a bit then then
we'll do that but it'll be a lot faster
if we can use what's already built in to
materialize so I'm gonna stick with
they're calling classes I can use
normally in react you have to use class
name
instead of class but I'm using a I
always forget the name of it but you can
check out the package.json file for this
project on github and you can see it I'm
using an NPM module that allows me to
use just the normal HTML syntax I guess
for for the HTML attributes so I can
just use class so just wanted to say
that in case it throws anyone off who's
maybe used to react and that's a little
weird to you so we're gonna use column
s12 okay so since these are gonna be
full with columns everything's just as
siliceous means on a small screen size
it's 12 columns and it's just gonna stay
twelve columns on all screen sizes so
within that we want to have an image and
in text so I think what I want to do
I think I'm actually gonna have some
nested columns I mean that would be that
would be the best here at least for now
so I don't think I don't think I need to
put this in a row and then more columns
I'm just gonna try to put a column right
in here I'm not sure what it'll do but
it won't take long to test it out
oops so let's do column and I want this
to be should I make on a small stream I
guess it can stack so we will do s 12 on
a small screen but then on medium
screens we want this to take up probably
25% of the screen
we'll try 25% at first maybe I wanted to
look slightly bigger than that but this
should work for now
and then within there we want to have an
image and for now I'm just gonna put in
just like a stock photo
so my other screen I'm just gonna find a
stock photo grab the URL and put it in
so
let's see if this one works
and then our our next oops
our next column is going to be where all
the text is so we'll just put in some
stuff here just so that we can get an
idea of what it's going to look like
just once again on small screens it's
gonna be 12 oops cycling skills are not
great today alright so we want small
screens who want to be full with and
then on medium screens we want this to
take up the rest so this is gonna be
nine columns materialise use just a
twelve column system so as long as
everything adds up to twelve then then
you're good I guess you could go smaller
than twelve if you want so you can't go
more than twelve so within there let's
just throw in just throwing something to
see what its gonna look like and then we
can adjust it later so I know we're
gonna have a title and I don't know that
I want H tags for everything else I
think I'll just do spans and we'll just
give them a class I want this to be
author and let's just say it's me since
I'm doing this right now and then I
think what else what else do we have
oh we have a type I'll just put that
here for now I haven't decided for sure
where we're gonna specify like what type
of resource it is then we'll just say
it's audio just pretend that I recorded
an awesome song and that's the resource
should be crazy I can't sing at all and
then we'll just have a paragraph and I
guess I'll give it a class oops
that's not what I wanted we'll give it a
class of the description and usually I'd
like to give materialised comes with
this this class called flow text which
makes the the font size change depending
on the screen width I normally go with
that for text but I'm not for now I just
want to see what it looks like without
at first and if it's readable so for now
I'm just gonna some lorem ipsum just
because that'll be the fastest to do
okay
let's save that see what happens whoa
and let me show you what happened this
is - so since I'm using masonry on this
it's just all these cars just covered up
everything that we did so that's no good
also my image that was supposed to be
Bill Murray just didn't work so two
disappointments there wow that's Thanks
so here's what I'm gonna do I am gonna
have to take these out to make this work
so let's remove
yeah let's just remove this and that
should give us what we need just to be
able to see what's going on okay so
that's that's roughly really really
roughly what I was going for but I
definitely want to see what it looks
like with an image so oh I see why is
not letting me
so as it failed to get the resource so
this is where I was getting it from me
say this was supposed yeah it's supposed
to work
oh wait maybe I needed the HTTP maybe
this just needs updated because it it's
without the s all right let's try that
so I should just need to add this and
hopefully it'll work no still didn't
work
all right one more time before I put in
all right oh well I just have to put in
an image that I already have and I know
we'll work so let me check my image
folder I think all these images in this
folder are huge
actually let me check the live chat
maybe one of you are seeing what's going
on here and can help me out also I
haven't checked the live chat a couple
minutes I don't want to leave you all
hanging
Oh Naveen asked about with that dot
filter and map were so let me okay it
looks like Rohan gave a good answer to
that so so awesome basically it's just a
way to work with arrays so that you can
filter out and only get the items that
you want from an array map lets you just
go through every item in array and do
something you know with each item so you
would use it maybe like in place of a
for loop
I see a couple of people's told me to do
get DIF to see what changed so I I
eventually remembered that
okay there's a discussion about code
editors which I love it like I wonder I
don't know that I've ever done in a live
stream without some discussion of code
editors in in the stream just always we
had somebody so Shaw says hey what's up
this is my first time tuning in how are
you doing I'm doing pretty good thank
you so much for joining in for the for
the live chat welcome
oh no Torrance says things were not good
today was a bad day I'm sorry to hear
that
hopefully things will get better
maybe I hope you have a good experience
with it within the live chat maybe
that'll be that'll be something me
something that's not bad in your day oh
I'm bear to asked about image size
constraints and that's a good question
at one time I did have size constraints
but I don't think it would apply I don't
think it would apply to where I put this
in here I think I had them somewhere up
here at least I thought I did
now I don't remember where I put the
image size constraints but it is right
at one time I had the constraints I'm
not gonna really need to have
constraints like I did before for this
layout which is one of the reasons why
we decided to go with this layout oh man
denna says what about cores so cross
what is the cross origin resource what's
the S stand for I can't remember
cross-origin resource sharing is that
what it is anyway that might be it
actually since I'm doing this from
localhost it might be freaking out and
not wanting me to it won't want to give
me the the image so all right yeah so I
won't work with that I won't mess with
the image anymore yeah actually I'm not
getting a coarse error in the console
I'm just kidding I'm just getting an
error I mean usually it says oh wait
here we go
it was just higher up in the console I
was getting multiple errors for it yep
you got it you all are right it is a
Corsair so let me switch and just get a
different image there is a way that you
can I forget what the site is there's a
way you can get around course errors I
used it I was building the weather app
from free code camps lessons and I used
it to get around the dark sky API course
issues but I can't remember what it was
so I'm not gonna try to find it now I'm
just gonna go to unsplash and I'm gonna
grab just an image from there this
should give me a random image I'm gonna
have the random image one
and sometimes I like doing the random
image from unsplash shot I T because
then you you don't get bored hopefully I
don't get a Corsair with this one yes
okay no coarser great
so I mean probably the ideal image
dimensions would not be this but it just
gives us an idea of okay we have an
image here we'll see how it's gonna work
all right so this is the basic layout
that I that I want now but now that you
all can see what I was saying in my mind
what I want is I don't know that I want
it to be this tall so maybe a little bit
smaller and the images that would then
be smaller this description would be
hidden by default and you'd be able to
click to read the description so maybe
it just might say read more you'd be
able to click and then it would drop
down and you'd be able to see it so they
would basically be half this the height
of this but then every item would just
take up space in this row potentially I
don't know if I'm gonna attempt this or
not but potentially if a screen was wide
enough there would be enough space that
we could do two rows side by side but I
don't want to mess with that because
then I have to worry about the the rows
being the same height and I just don't
want to deal with that I know that there
are ways like using flexbox to make sure
they're the same height but at this
point I only have until the 20th of this
month to get all the features done for
this site so you can see I have a Trello
board with all the stuff that needs to
get done and it's linked in the
description and there's still quite a
lot so that's gonna fall under probably
like hey we'll do it if we have time but
it's not 100% necessary so you know for
most people something would I don't
remember what the average screen size is
but this is probably closer to
but a lot of people would be seeing the
audience for this site is not likely to
have really awesome
computers with giant screens so I should
probably keep that in mind that I think
this the screen I'm working on now is a
2k 20
I think it's 27-inch screen so
definitely not what people would
normally have who would be our audience
but anyway this is the the basic thing
so now we're just gonna fine tune it a
bit I want to get the UI completely like
ready how we like it before I actually
pull in the data and then have a lot of
them stacked up so I might just once we
get it to a point where it looks pretty
nice then I'll I'll just copy like three
of them just to see what they look like
stacked up and we'll probably do some
sort of really thin border between them
and if everything is good then we'll
plug in the data and and see how it
looks
my only fear is that it's gonna be a
long list there's gonna be a long scroll
associated which I mean it's kind of
unavoidable you know because this I'm
kind of stuck I can't go back to the old
layout I'm a little bit stuck and that
it needs to be pretty much like this
this is what they want but hopefully
with all these categories and options
and search anything can be narrowed down
enough so that there won't be too many
items here all right so I'm gonna
continue on with this if you have any
questions at this point if you're lost
or there's something you really didn't
understand about what I'm doing let me
know right now oh I'm gonna take a drink
really quick and then I'm gonna check
the live chat before we move on and
continue styling this
okay so
someone did ask about saying use
classname so Jonathan said replace class
with class name so I explained this a
little while ago but maybe Jonathan
joined in after that so just really
quick
you notice I'm using class here and I'm
not getting errors it actually works I
have a plug-in that lets me use class
normally you can't use class with react
but it's X it's really useful to be able
to use it if you're copy and pasting
HTML which in this case I do somewhat
frequently from the materialised
documentation so it's really helpful to
not have to change class the class name
so this was from some of the old code
before I had that plug-in and I didn't
install that plug-in someone else
installed it so let me bring up I like
to show this from time to time just so I
can give everyone credit for their
contributions so here's the contributors
to the repo so I'm trying to think who I
think it was Danny that actually
submitted a request a pull request and
installed that plug-in so thanks Danny
for that so if you want your github
profile featured on this show then
submit a pull request how's this I don't
expect anyone to take time out of their
day to contribute to this project but if
you would like to and you have the time
then uh it's really nice I'll appreciate
it and you know as long as it improves
the project somewhat then you know I'll
pull it in okay so let me let me check
the the live chat quickly and then we'll
move on
ah raj area is says he's watching this
in one 144p can't even read the code
really sorry that you have to watch it
in 144p so i'll if you're still tuned in
and haven't just gotten frustrated and
left I'll try to be as descriptive as
possible and what I'm saying even though
you can't see it that well that really
stinks I'm sorry about that I don't I
mean I don't think I could do anything
about that it's it's you know the
internet connection at the other end but
oh man Turin tour I mentioned earlier
that they're having a really bad day and
I don't know if they want me to read off
what they said so I'm not gonna read off
what they said but it just seems like
they're having a really really bad day
so if you're still here I'm really
really sorry I'm available on Twitter if
you want to direct message me and if you
need to talk about anything I'm here for
you
so that's things sometimes
I myself have battled with clinical
depression since I was probably 17 or 18
I mean and I'm 31 now so I definitely
understand when when you get down
so I'm here for anybody that ever needs
to talk about that or anything cuz it
can be rough I'm not a counselor though
so this is not like official medical
advice or anything it's just somebody
who's been through it so
Danis Anton says will you cover setting
up a register slash login not on this
project I won't need to in this project
but possibly on future projects I will
need to do that so I can't guarantee I
can't give you a time yet because I'm
not entirely in control of my schedule
it's whatever my bosses want me to work
on so but I can definitely foresee in
the future me having to do that on some
some potential projects that I know are
in the works so maybe one day
potentially I could maybe just do a
video like on my own channel pre record
something to go over registration login
maybe I'll add that to my list of of
topics or potential topics for videos
alright so I'm going to I'm just going
to get started I know there's some more
questions in the live chat I'll get to
those later on if you're if you've asked
a question and you can stick around till
the end I'll answer all the questions if
you can't stick around you could always
I'll answer it you know you can watch
the recording later on or you can
message me on Twitter or put it in the
comments and then I can get to it later
on all right Dana Stanton asked what my
channel is the link I have a link in the
description for this video I actually
can't even remember what the with the
address is right now it's probably just
my name but oh but it's in the
description so okay here's what I'm
thinking that we ought to do I kind of
think this title is just a little bit
too big so maybe I'll drop this down
into an h4 it's an h3 right now so we'll
drop this down to an h4 these need to be
on two different lines and it might be
maybe I might want them to be a
different color we'll see well mess with
maybe making them this red color also I
have this kind of goldish color that
might work we'll see how sometimes the
gold
there isn't really that readable so
we'll see but it might work I think it'd
be nice to have at least one of these be
different color and then we'll have to
hide this and then put in a little
button that will show it and we'll
probably want to do some sort of
animation so that it looks just a little
bit more smooth maybe not even I mean we
might just do like a little transition
or something
nothing fancy I think that's that's
probably it also will probably want to
do something with a salmon suit right
now the the height of this is obviously
being set by the image right so if I
want this to be shorter what I ideally
what I want is the height of this to not
be set by the image but instead to be
set by the text so we'll have to adjust
the styles for this image so that you
know it isn't always taking up this full
height here and then finally we're gonna
have a little border probably web you
know like a bottom border alright so
that's the that's the plan right now so
let's go back to the code so first
things first let's drop this down to an
h4 also we need to make something in
here linked so potentially the title
could be a link so I'm gonna just make
it a link right now and I just want to
see what color it makes this link
automatically I think the default right
now is blue I don't want the title to be
I don't think I want the title be blue
we'll see what it looks like but it's
really not a part of the color scheme
for this so we'll probably end up making
it maybe this red color and then yeah I
want this to be
oops not class style and now if you're
not familiar with how to do Styles and
react one way to do it is to put it in
line as a JavaScript object so in react
when you're in this is called JSX
this kind of HTML looking stuff in here
so if you want to put JavaScript in the
middle of it you just put it a little
curly bracket and then now anything
between these these first curly brackets
is JavaScript so now that I've put
another set of curly brackets that's
just an object and so within that object
we can put CSS attributes but we have to
camelcase them so for instance if we
wanted to put like font weight we'd have
to do it like like that instead of the
normal hyphenated CSS selector okay so
this is just one way to do it there are
many different ways to do CSS in react
but this is just one so for this one I'm
just gonna do color and I need to grab a
hex code so I'm just going to pull on my
other screen I'm gonna pull up dev tools
just so I can grab that same color that
is in the footer and that's the hex code
we're working with so you want to make
sure that you put in in this case I'm
using single quotes but you could
probably use double quotes and it
wouldn't matter
you know the actual value of the
attribute you want to put inside quotes
if you just have just a plain number it
will probably work without the quotes
but I just put everything in quotes for
consistency if you wanted to do
something else you just put a comma and
then put another attribute and you could
just go on just just like you would
normally do a JavaScript object so let's
what else did we want to do oh we wanted
to make these actually mean let me see I
if I do oops not distribute
display:block I think this will make the
other thing pop down on to a separate
line so we wanted to do that so we've
made that a different color let's just
try out that gold color I don't really
have much hope that it will work I think
it's gonna end up being too hard to read
but we'll give it a shot
so let me grab the gold color once again
on my other screen just from dev tools
okay so that's our gold color and then
for this
let's go display:none for now oops and
then finally for the image let's go with
I'm not sure what is the one right now
I know for sure I want the height to be
Auto but I'm not sure that'll fix our
problem right now because if the width
is said yeah we'll see I'll just leave
it for that now I'm I'm doubtful that
that'll fix it but yeah and it's true it
didn't fix it but let me see what this
did let me show you show you what this
did okay so as I thought blue is the
default color for a link I don't think
we're gonna keep blue I mean you you you
all can tell me what you think but I
just don't think that this color blue
really goes with the color scheme as you
can see you know we're kind of that like
a black black you know this dark red and
white and then I really only kind of
accent color that we've used as this
gold
this actually is way more readable than
I thought it would be so I think I might
keep it I was worried it would be hard
to read I'll have to try it out on maybe
some screens that aren't as
high-resolution just to make sure
but for now I'm okay with that I
definitely want to change this color and
I think make it the red color and I
don't know that I like these being two
different colors so maybe this will be
this will either be red or the the gold
and then the other two will be the
opposite color the paragraph will end up
being just the regular font color which
i think is black with an opacity of 87%
okay so I'm gonna open up dev tools and
I'm gonna inspect this really quick so I
can see what's going on with the image
and let me bring it over so I hate to do
too much on the other screen where you
can't see wow that's an issue
check check that up
that's just going right over so we
definitely don't want that I'm not sure
maybe this is because we tried to nest
columns and maybe that's not the right
way to do it so I'm not gonna worry
about this right now we'll wait until we
do a bit more but we'll have to fix that
but I did want to see yeah I kind of
like how that stacks it's not not too
bad but let me make this a lot bigger
for you all here's our image and we can
see in dev tools all the properties here
what I'm really worried about here is
width and height so I'm assuming that
the width is set to I don't know what a
hundred percent maybe the width not set
at all it doesn't look like it's even
set so let's just you know let's play
around a bit and see what we can do oops
I can't
okay so if we set it to a hundred it
actually looks better here but it's not
gonna look better when we make it bigger
so it's gonna look worse okay so we
don't want it to be a hundred I actually
want the images my idea for images is
that all the images will be in this
upper left-hand corner and then whatever
their normal sizes they'll remain that
size unless they're bigger than I want
in which case though they'll have to be
a maximum size so it'd be something like
max width would be a hundred percent so
I would never want it to be you know
bigger but potentially could be smaller
so maybe really I could probably set I
could set a maximum height because we'll
know as long as the titles don't get
huge I mean four it would have to be for
each break point we would have a
different maximum height
but I'm gonna think about what I want to
do there for now let's sort this out
with kind of what I said a few minutes
ago and get that looking how we want it
to look and we need a border here and
then I'd like to duplicate it a few
times to see what it looks like stacked
and then also we need a button to show
that that description all right so we'll
work on that now actually let me look
let me check back in with the live chat
because it's been it's been a few
minutes I don't want to miss too much
okay yeah danish anton subscribed to my
mind chant my personal channel so thank
you thank you for that i don't want i
haven't been able to put up as many
videos that i had planned
I'm just been busier than I thought so
sorry about that but I hope to put up
some some nice you know short tutorial
videos on there as soon as I can
alex says materializes to puck and
bootstrap is biggie so if you're
familiar with 90s American rap feuds
then you'll know what that refers to but
I think everybody knows Tupac and Biggie
right if you don't there are just two
famous rappers that had feuds which may
or may not have been legit I always have
my doubts about celebrity feuds I think
most of them are orchestrated to
increase publicity but I did I never
took sides in that phew
okay bill says the trick I've heard is
if you make everything monochrome with
an overlay using maybe Photoshop and
can't read something then the design
colors might need to be changed cool
I've never heard that that's that's a
good good trick
Rogerio says I know nothing about next
Jay asks would you mind tell me in short
what it is what it's about and actually
it's some people and the live chat gave
some good answers to that just my short
answer to next jazz is it's a way to
very quickly start building with react
and have server-side rendering built in
routing built in so you don't have to
set that up you don't have to worry
about setting up web pack comes with hot
module reloading so you can very very
quickly start using react without having
to learn a lot of the other stuff that
at least in my experience slowed me down
a lot at first so there are plenty of
other awesome things about next Jas but
for me at least this that's kind of the
core of what's what's great about it
okay so Alex is the blue is not working
I definitely agree
Alex asks about how how I got my code
editor to show the color of the hex so
this is I'm using Adam from github and
it's just a plugin I don't remember I'm
sorry I don't remember what the plug-in
is but it was just a plugin for the code
editor to show the the colors
as anna says if they had a color scheme
to stick with at least you could blame
them if it didn't pass an accessibility
audit yeah that's true I really have no
control over this color scheme at this
point so this was the color scheme that
I inherited when I took over this the
development of the site so a lot of
decisions had already been made if
you've been watching from like the start
of this when I started this site there
was already a partially completed site
that I was starting from and I had to I
didn't have to keep all of it but I did
have to keep some of the design elements
and the color scheme I definitely had to
keep
all right so I've got through everything
in that in the live chat for the most
part so let's get back to this okay
l-o-l Brito says Adam the Adam package
is called pigments for the hex colors so
thank you very much for for putting that
in the in the chat so if anybody's
interested in getting their getting
colors here pigments is the package for
Adam I'm sure there are similar packages
for other code editors so let's change
that that color and let's see I'm just
gonna copy this since this is pretty
much what we want I don't need this part
though just copy that and I'm gonna use
this color here I also want to increase
the font size of both of these
as these start to get bigger in terms of
you know adding more CSS in this I like
to put them down in here in this style
JSX tag so at some point I'll probably
do that but for now it's just a lot less
scrolling and it's probably easier for
you all to see if I put it in here so if
it gets really huge and unmanageable I
will move it down but for now I think
it'll be fine so let's go with font size
and I'm not sure what font size we have
now but I think I'm gonna I'm gonna see
what 18 pixels looks like oops if I can
type 18 there we go let's put it here as
well might look nicer if these are a
little bit different but for now we'll
just try it also we need a button right
so I'm not sure if I want an actual you
know button or just some text for now
it'll be easiest to just put some text
we'll just say give it a class of read
more for now and I'll just say read more
and I guess we could do you give it an
on-click
in
I was just thinking for a second if I
could fit everything I wanted this to do
right into here if I should just make a
different function we'll see I don't
have to think about it right now
for now though I just want to hmm I
think how I should how a lot to do this
I guess I'll have to say that right now
so we're just doing the u.s. stuff right
now so I shouldn't I shouldn't be mixing
in this this stuff of right now it'll
just slow us down
let's see we wanted finally we wanted a
a border right so what his style and
I'm gonna do a border bottom and let's
do I want it to be really thin so I
think I'm just gonna go two pixels at
first see how that looks and we want it
to be solid and I think I would like it
to be some type of gray maybe I'll just
use
whenever I need to make an RGB color
instead of typing it out myself I just
come in here and I think if I made it 54
I can change it but basically if I do it
like this then I don't have to type it
up and I can preview the colors so
occasionally it saves me some time so
let's put that in there and I'm gonna
try 54 let's see how that looks
oops well alright so we had the border
didn't do anything at all right now I
don't need that in there also I need to
make this
okay there we go
while two pixels this way - that's way
thicker than I wanted we're gonna have
to go down to one pixel actually I don't
really mind this right now at least we
in the same color I think they may be
you should be closer to here so we need
to decrease the padding for that title
tag and then we need to increase the
padding between these two because the
serene more should be down here the read
more right now it doesn't indicate at
all that it's clickable so we need to
make that have a better indication of
click ability and we'll make this
smaller so let's drop this down to one
pixel and let's say
we did it padding-bottom I think it's
patting your nut margin we'll find out
in a second here oops padding-bottom and
we'll do let's see if eight pixels will
be too much okay so that thickness there
that I like that that's not too bad I'm
not I'm not sure that I like it being
all the way across like that I don't
know if it needs to be we'll see how it
looks though whenever we get more on
there maybe it'll look better so that
padding didn't do anything so maybe it's
a margin thing it is it's a margin oops
and I put it I actually put it on the a
tag which which wouldn't do anything
anyway all right so let's take this
take this off and on the actual H tag
will do margin-bottom and we'll try
eight pixels
I'm not sure that did much of anything
did it yeah that's so the exact amount
all right let's try oh it's not why is
it not doing anything
that's odd
all right we'll drop that down then a
half I guess
okay all right that brought it up a bit
I guess it's okay
let's share this font size and then we
brought it up to 18 but I think 20 might
be even better yeah like 20
all right so I must have the worst
Spotify playlist ever playing right now
on my headphones I normally don't mess
with Spotify at all during the streams
cuz but I have to change this it's just
it's just not it's the new music Friday
playlist for this Friday on Spotify and
it's just not great today so I'm gonna
change that all right let me I'm gonna
check the live chat since it's been a
while okay not much going on in the live
shows I haven't missed that much Oh
Alex said that Adam always crashes so I
had to switch back to sublime so that's
things I've never used sublime I've seen
people on YouTube using sublime it it
looks like a nice code editor okay
Sebastian says color highlighter works
for sublime so if you're using sublime
and you want the hex colors color
highlighter it will work
yeah bill Cicero music really throw you
off your game for sure I like it just
makes it so much harder to focus when
the music is annoying to you jack says
Jessie sounds like Evan Peters to me now
I can't separate the two of them in my
head I don't know who Evan Peters is
who's Evan Peters does not want to
listen to them and see if he sounds like
me all right so let's go back and see
what else we need thought we need to
work on this read more hmm
well for sure the read more needs to be
a different color I'm running out of
colors of highlight colors I guess I'm
gonna have to make this one red well we
don't really have any other colors that
are already being in use unless
something to go back to the blue or pull
in some entirely different color so
we'll make this red we will make it so
that your cursor looks like a link
cursor so let's do that
okay so you want the color to be I
couldn't just copy and pasted this whole
thing here oh wow and cursor cursor
pointer this has been the most CSS heavy
stream I've done for a long time so if
you were here for a lot of JavaScript
sorry but I know a lot of people really
wanted more CSS stuff at least a while
back there are a lot of people that
wanted more CSS that were kind of a
little lost with all the react stuff so
hopefully some of them are watching and
are getting something useful out of this
all right so this is more like what we
want oh we wanted to add some padding
there so let's do this we'll do a margin
margin top let's dress 16 pixels and see
what that looks like
that's weird didn't do anything
this didn't look like anything
that's weird
nice because it's not yeah I didn't set
it to display:block that's my fault
okay that's better yeah I don't know if
it needs to be 16 but for now that'll
work
okay I wondered I guess it's not it
looked like this was indented a bit but
I think it's just because it's a t just
looked indented which I didn't I don't
want it to be indented so I don't know I
don't know that I like audio being here
maybe I'll have to think maybe there's a
better place I think it might look nicer
if it was title and then author and then
this was somewhere else so I wouldn't I
actually wouldn't even be opposed to
using icons because our options are
either going to be video text or audio
you know we could definitely find pretty
straightforward icons for each one I
don't know if I want to go through
finding icons right now it's not I guess
it's not that difficult okay all right
at this point I think I would like to
see what a few of these look like
stacked together so let's try that
before we get any further
oh man okay that looked terrible at
first but it's just because the images
didn't load
that doesn't look too bad was everyone
thing actually looking at right now I
think the image section could be larger
there's a ton of space over here
you know we have multiple ones I could
just try to you just change one of them
and see what it looks like compared to
the other ones so we can make this 4 and
this 8 and then we'll try a different
one so we'll make this 5 and this 7 and
then we'll leave the other one as it was
just to get an idea ok so let's see
we'll have a vote
lay out 1 2 or 3 or none of them and do
something else now we will these are a
little bit short so I guess you know the
title is gonna probably gonna take up a
decent amount of space so maybe it would
look better if if it was actually filled
out I'm gonna do that for this one as
well so I'll give everyone in the live
chat a minute to to add weigh in on this
decision if you can if you want to and
I'll I'll put in some more data
okay
it just occurred to me I don't know why
I just occurred to me that I ought to
actually put like author : and then have
something here so that people will know
that it's the author
actually this doesn't look nearly as bad
now that it has a longer and longer
title I'm gonna check the live chat see
what you all think
okay Patrick says we could stagger the
images left and right bill likes the
stagger idea Sebastian says too much
space maybe more spacing between the
bottom border and next section Andrew
likes number one layout one manish says
none of them it's too much space rohan
says three looks best but also a
vertically center the text blog Phillip
says way too much space on all of them
Sebastian says Center the image inside
of the div if possible Phillip says
there's a lot of margin on the right of
the image patrick says plus one for
author label Genesis I think you need
some margin top on the border okay cool
all right so if we vertically center the
text that'll take care of the margin top
thing for the most part unless we have
something with insanely long title that
rats so let's do that first
so let's see if we take
let's take this and make it give it a
class of feline rapper and then no wait
I don't want that to be I want this to
have the class of v-line rapper and I
probably could do it for all of them so
okay and then within this we can make it
V line
all right let's see if that works
so materialized comes with some vertical
alignment stuff built in that's really
helpful because you don't have to mess
with it so here's what it looks like if
the text is vertically aligned
okay they were saying the image almost
sits on the border yeah you're right we
need to do something about the image
actually let's try this the image
there's no reason the image couldn't be
vertically aligned as well I'll shut on
this one first and then what if we set
the height to always be no I don't know
if this will work but we'll see let's
see
I might need I might need to use
something more absolutely yeah that's
not going to work
to see if this would work
okay so the vertical alignment would
work but yet we still need some sort of
padding because potentially if it was
this small it would be it would come
right up there
so actually we could probably just do
give this section this whole section a
bit of padding yeah let's do that
okay so let's just do do these big
sections here and we'll give them give
them awesome padding
oops
let's just give them a little padding
for now see how that looks
I don't know I think it needs more and
perhaps a bit more padding which I try
to double it
okay not quite as bad
are we getting it's a little off I think
we it's throwing it off the alignment
because this title has its own margin at
the top yeah so that's throwing
everything off I'm gonna take away the
top margin from the title so that it's
not throwing because right now it very
Clea looks like it's down a bit lower
than it should be if we were trying to
Center it completely because we have
this invisible space up here that's
adding height to this element so I'm
going to take that out and then we
should get a truer vertical line so
where's that all our H fours
okay there we go so that gives us a
better vertical line the only one that
looks weird
this one looks weird because it doesn't
have any border yeah every all the other
ones look like they have a top and a
bottom border but you know it's really
just the bottom border for all of them
so I don't know maybe it would look
better if there was a border on the top
just for the first one
oops border tough
okay I don't know if it makes it look
better but at least they get a better
idea of what these this padding looks
like
I'm gonna go back to the live show just
to check in with everyone
okay Santa asks would you have text in
there on the right and I hadn't thought
of that but now that I see it and I see
all this space that actually would be
well actually I will say like none of
the titles are gonna be so let me let's
get an idea of what the average title is
going to be anyway cuz I would I think
most of the titles are pretty long so
we're not actually gonna have a lot of
space here but let's I'm gonna go to the
live site okay so yeah all right some of
the titles are kind of short some of
them are longer you know this one is
definitely definitely a bit longer I
don't want to click the link okay so
anyway so yeah I mean if we were gonna
have everything be this short I think it
would be good to put text here I just
know that so the people are making this
a four seem to really like long titles
like really long titles so that's been
it's been difficult for me to try to fit
in all these titles I have a lot of like
wrapping of text going on where it
shouldn't be so I'm just trying like
thinking it is likely that the titles
for these things will end up being huge
especially once they see how much more
space they have here than they did in
the the cards and even this author thing
is not necessarily even going to be
someone's name it could potentially be
like multiple names so if this is a
video with more than one person or a
book with more than one person I mean
this could end up being like four names
and if you look some of the names are
crazy because it's not just a name
to name Plus like all the degrees that
they've had after that so I'm thinking
that this space is more than likely
going to be taken up actually once we
pull in the real data it'll be way
easier to see that so for now I am gonna
leave a space here and then when we pull
in the data if we find that we're still
having a decent amount of space then
maybe we could put a small amount of
text there but I definitely want four
just so that users don't have to scroll
too much
I would like these to be shorter rather
than taller so it's thing obviously once
it gets down you know to where these
stack that has to change because there's
no way they'll be able to stack properly
I don't know hmm I'm actually not
entirely sure that they should stack
when it gets lower I mean there'd be
some crazy text wrapping going on but
now let's see what this looks like
okay that's more reasonable I think if I
Center that image that that actually is
more reasonable so maybe they ought to
stack I think actually like I looked
better here on a smaller more narrow
screen than on the large one
the title I gave this is just nonsense
and ridiculous but in that font it just
it looks like impressive doesn't it well
you could write anything in this font
and it would look impressive all right
let's see
Oh Roland's going to sleep thanks for
thanks for watching and thank you thanks
for contributing I appreciate it it's a
what is it about two o'clock in the
morning where you're at so that's
awesome for staying up that late just
just for this l Bri so says what about
two per row yeah we talked about two per
row earlier that's still potentially an
option I don't want to make a decision
on the two per row until I actually get
the real data in here and see how much
space is being taken up and then oh I
think we'll have a much better feel for
just how much you know extra space we
have because even with this I mean I
could move this over more I suppose but
it would still you know this is a really
wide screen let me move this screen down
into what a more normal screen would be
so I guess a more normal desktop screen
would end up being like this so so
looking at it from this perspective this
actually looks a lot nicer and more
balanced so I haven't checked the
analytics for a while but I don't think
we get many users that have really wide
screens so even as we go out
I mean even getting into this with you
know that's that's still reasonable
we're getting a bit more white space but
it would definitely you know it's
reasonable and it would be tough to
squeeze it in to too
but I definitely want to do something
about these images
because I really have no idea what
dimensions the images are going to be in
there could be all different ones so I
don't want to make assumptions about
what the image is going to be like or
design based on a certain image
dimension because it could totally
change so all we all we want to do with
images is just set maximum maximum
Heights that they could be I guess
that's all we're really worried about so
that's what I'm gonna do so I'm gonna
look check the height of this image and
just get let's get a feel for like what
what is the biggest image that would
make sense here you know how big do we
want this like I'm thinkin I I guess I
really don't want it to be wider than
this or taller than this I mean that
that's honestly even a little bit taller
than I think I would 1 so what if the
max image height would be like maybe 200
is this decent for now I think I'm gonna
set it at 200 I'm gonna set it at 200
and then let's put in the real data and
just see what it looks like and then the
streams been going on for what at least
two hours now so that's it so well let's
put in the data see what it looks like
and then kind of wrap things up maybe
make a bit some more adjustments but I
think we got I mean it's definitely way
different than it was from the start so
and it's a lot closer to what I had
sketched on paper so it definitely needs
some work
I'm not I'm not happy with it as it is
now but it definitely gives me a good
idea I like to see that I think it might
be good to like sleep on it and come
back tomorrow and or what's Friday I'll
come back on Monday and hopefully my
subconscious will have worked on this
over the weekend yeah all right so let's
go back I do want to put this Mac site
in for the images right now and I'm only
gonna put this let's see which one did
we want to keep
actually I think I want to keep the
spacing for this one now that I see it
with a longer title so this will be the
one that we keep so let's put in max
height
of 200 pixels it's crazy
I keep glancing at the analytics for the
video and it's crazy like as the video
goes on the viewership just drops off I
guess it makes sense you know like
everybody gets the notification at first
and they check it out so I mean that's
the big burst but like we've dropped
like half of the amount of years we had
you know like in the first half an hour
I'm not complaining about it I'm just
like observing that it's interesting
like you know that we get I'm just
always interested in certain times
during the video it picks up and it
drops off and I just I've no idea why
you know there are different patterns I
guess and in the people viewing alright
so we don't need these anymore so I do
want so for now I'm gonna leave this
like this but obviously I'm gonna make
this its own component you know and it's
it's going to be a separate file and a
separate component but for now just to
test this out we'll just leave it all
here what I want to do is I want to give
this a class so I can put more easily
put the padding top I want to move I
want to move a bunch of these styles
down not right now but let's give it a
class of resource resource row I guess
they're all rows now so that kind of
makes sense the code a resource row and
then down here I'm just going to do one
thing
research will i always forget what these
are what is it first I'll just look it
up I think there's like a first of type
and a first I guess I guess first of
type is what I want right this don't use
these often enough to to remember them
and now we want to give this the border
I'm gonna copy this this is what we want
you so much gonna copy this part
there we go okay let's make sure I
didn't pull out anything really
important okay cool so we have the
border at the top great
all right now let's put this so here's
what we want we want to drop down into
JavaScript now and we want to get this
state data and then we want to map that
right and we map that we're going to
call it will just call this it's been
call each one resource right usually I
just call it post let's go I'll just
call cocos2d consistent with everything
else that I have going on so we can use
this arrow function and this will just
return all of this
so now within post we can get obviously
this will eventually be an image URL I
kind of want to leave this in for now
just so we get an idea of what it looks
like with images now you know what I'm
going to change it because not
everything is gonna have an image so I
do want to see what they look like
without images and if it looks good
interspersed with some that do have
images so let me get I have the this is
what the the data is gonna look like so
we'll have where's our image okay so we
need to do a CF URL I'm gonna put this
on my other screen so I can see it as
where as I'm putting it in so for source
it's actually gonna be we're gonna have
to do some logic in here so it's gonna
say post dot a CF has a zone property I
think that's what it's called has been
property now you know what it is gonna
have URL no matter what let me check
this up
no I don't want I'm sorry I thought it
was gonna be a CF URL it's gonna be
better featured image so what I want to
say is post better featured image and
then I want to make sure that it's not
equal to null
it's not equal to null then I want to
put in I want to use the post
better featured image otherwise this is
gonna look terrible for now and I need
to do it what I need to do is is check
this all somewhere else and then just
put it in for now unless I can just copy
it quickly I might still have it up here
then you just copy it to the resource
card I don't know what's working how was
that
I guess I was annoying it like that I
was thinking that if I just added a
blank source that it would give me that
weird little box that says there's no
image so we'll just leave it like that
for now we'll leave it like this for now
and what else do we need we need the
title so let's with a curly bracket
we're gonna go into JavaScript land here
and let's get post ACF and actually it's
just title post title rendered so we
have that and now for the for the author
it's just thing about the author not all
of them have an author yet so I am gonna
have to check first so what we do want
it to say is we wanted to say author :
and then a space then we want to check
and see post ACF has property
and if it says author then we're going
to use post otherwise we're not going to
do anything
and for this we're gonna do post whoops
gonna go into JavaScript toast dot ACF
dots type and then although we're not
using this right now may as well put it
in I mean it's all it's hidden for now
and for this one since it could
potentially have HTML in it I want to do
dangerously set inner HTML I can use
this and be confident with it because
the data I'm being it's being pulled in
is from WordPress a wordpress
installation I have control of it's not
a good idea to pull in data this way
from sources that you don't have control
of because potentially you know harmful
stuff could get pulled in so use with
caution obviously because it's just
dangerously set it but we're gonna live
dangerously today and put in put this in
and let me think is it trying to
remember how this is yeah I think that's
what it how you do it
oops I just I just noticed the typo
sorry title there we go post AC is a VCF
yeah description okay and that's what we
need for now
oops I'm sorry I forgot one very
important thing we need the URL and
that's gonna be post dot a CF dot URL
and then let's go ahead and put in a
title tag we'll just do post a CF our
post title rendered there we go now I'll
save it and let's see what happens
getting a long refresh here let me
restart my dev server cuz it seems like
I messed it up luckily this only takes
about three seconds
all right so we did have a problem and
this was where I went to set dangerously
set innerhtml
so let's see I know that I've
dangerously said it somewhere else so
I'm just gonna look at where I did it
elsewhere and copy that there we go oh
okay
I forgot another set of brackets I was
kind of thinking I needed another set of
Arrakis
I think I don't know if you can hear
that on here but I just heard thunder
outside and I didn't bring my umbrella
today so I was gonna bring my umbrella
and then one of my daughter's said I
want to use the umbrella so I let her
have the umbrella so now I'm I'm
umbrella this for today
okay so I'll shoot I need to dangerously
set innerhtml in these titles so that
these characters look right but other
than that shoot I forgot to since I'm on
localhost I can't pull in images from
WordPress either so that won't let me so
maybe it actually it doesn't look
terrible
it looks a little weird for the for ones
without images here's an idea suit you
think what if the image was on this side
then the text would be over here so if
there wasn't an image which is likely
for some of them that they're not going
to be an image it wouldn't it wouldn't
look offset so like if there was an
image here then this one would what do
you think what do you think about that
I'm gonna check the live chat since I
haven't checked in well anyway but I
would like to know if we moved it so
that images appear too over here with
that would that be okay now what I think
about it I think it might
okay bill says maybe add some styling to
an HR tag to have it fade on the left
and right side that's a great idea I
hadn't I can't believe I didn't even
think of an HR tag instead of a border
that that's a really good idea thanks
for that bill
sebastien acts where the text will go
when you click read more this will just
get bigger and there'll be text here and
then there'll be an option to to
minimize it again
Zanna says give them say like 10 10 vh
for the for the image height okay yeah I
do I like going with using VH if you're
not familiar the VH is its viewport
height so if I said 10 viewport height
as the image height then it would take
up like 10 percent of the current the
height of the viewport in the same way
with VW you port with and it works the
same way
Philip s can you render server-side with
react if you are you if you're using go
I don't know I've never used it with go
I they're not not read anything about
that so I'm sorry but I can't I can't
really give you an accurate answer for
that
Nathan caught the title spelled wrong
before I did so sorry I didn't I didn't
look over at the live chat but thanks
for pointing that out Athan bill says if
there's no author will it say author no
actually long as I was typing that out I
thought it probably shouldn't say
authors should just be nothing I can
make it so that author is a required
field if I want to but I don't think I
really want to because you know maybe
they don't I mean I think everything
would have to have somebody that made it
but just in case I should make it so
that nothing would show up instead of
author
okay Andrew says image on the right
would be better okay bill says that he
has the an allow control origin star
which is like all chrome plug-in to let
me get around the localhost course
issues but it says we're to word to the
wise disable that when done or you will
have headaches okay that's actually that
might be useful for this project Andrew
asks what the client is going to input
data with in WordPress so the client
will be the content management system
for all this is WordPress and then it
gets pulled in here okay so I think I'm
gonna wrap things up now cuz it's been a
pretty long stream we're at two and a
half out oh I forgot I started this
dream late so we're not into an effort
we're actually only about two hours I
started a half hour later than normal
but it's still a really long stream at
two hours so I think I think I'm going
to wrap it up here I'm gonna go back
through the live chat and make sure I
didn't miss anything right now and miss
any questions if if you don't want to
stick around for the question
question-and-answer session that we're
about to have then thanks for watching
and I'll see you next week thanks thanks
for being involved in the live chat
otherwise if you're gonna stick around
you have any questions put them in the
live chat or you can put them in the
comments to this video or if you're shy
you can direct message me on on Twitter
my the link to my Twitter profile is in
the description below and I'm definitely
gonna take into account all everything
that you all said whenever
I work on this and decide and then once
I get this down then I'll show it to
everyone else involved in this project
and they'll there may be some some other
things because that need to change based
on that but a decent work I'm I'm
satisfied that you know with with the
basics that we got here today this is
looking a lot closer to what it will end
up being okay so I'm gonna go back
through the live chat quickly if and it
looks like I've kept up with the live
chat pretty well so I don't think
there's a lot that I need to catch up on
so it won't take me too long so if you
have any questions put them up there
quickly
okay I saw weight really early on like
right at the beginning we were talking
about the 100 days of code challenge and
I had I had said I thought you can just
start whenever you want but I wasn't
sure and I didn't notice before but
Zanna says yeah you can just start
coding whenever and just keep it going
for a hundred days so thanks for that
answer sorry I didn't see it earlier
but and I'm not I'm not sure if the
person that asked about it is even in
here anymore
Navin or Naveen I'm not sure how to
pronounce your first name so sorry if
I'm mispronouncing it but that's who
asked the question initially but the
hundred days of code is a really cool
concept I actually haven't done it yet I
should do it because I I i usually code
usually I try not to I usually take
Sundays off and if I do any code it's
like fun stuff like I'm working on a
game with my oldest son so I'll code
that but other than that I code pretty
consistently Monday through Saturday so
I should just do it
okay still going through nothing new in
the live chat so I think I covered most
of it okay there was still I think I
mentioned before there was some
discussion about code editors and I kind
of skipped over it at the time but it
seems like some people are saying the
consensus always seems to be that Adam
is slow at least slower than all the
other editors that everyone uses so the
alternatives that were mentioned were
Visual Studio code brackets and sublime
okay here's a question so Thomas asked
in terms of workflow what would you
suggest to beginners in react as on how
to start their site creation should
think of the different components based
on wire framing or use a specific
approach yeah I mean I suppose it
depends on what would you already are
used to in which you like but if you're
starting like from a wireframe then yeah
you could you could actually just take
you know either within whatever program
you're using or even if you print it out
and are just a sketch you can just draw
a boxes around everything and each each
thing that you could draw a box around
could be its own separate component
usually it's a good idea to try to make
the components so that they only do one
thing so the smaller you can break down
components
it's normally better so as far as
specific approach I I don't know of any
approaches maybe there are but I mean I
don't know like if there's any official
approaches to to starting a project like
that
okay as Anna said she found a really
nice tutorial for react and it was
called react Jas tutorial number one -
react.js JavaScript introduction and
workspace setup on youtube so if you
search for that on YouTube I haven't
seen it yet so it's not really an
official endorsement but XANA seems to
be pretty knowledgeable from what from
all the contributions to the live chat
so it's probably a pretty legit video
under the watcher asks are you saving
the stream yeah the stream will be
available just a few minutes after it
ends it's available to watch the
recording so if you can't if you didn't
catch the entire stream or if you can't
stick around for the whole stream or
especially there there are people that
just this time of day because the time
zones it's just it doesn't work for them
to watch it or because of even if the
time zone thing is not a big deal
they're working or something at this
time so there's a lot of people that do
watch the recording well I appreciate
when when you make the effort to be in
the live chat if you can so it's really
nice to have everybody's contributions
Rogerio asks I don't think he's in here
anymore but maybe he'll watch the
recording are you developing on top of
WordPress I think I mentioned this at
some point
but yeah the content management system
is WordPress but what I'm working with
right now is is react so it's two
separate servers that are actually
running these sites and I just use
WordPress for the content management and
I pull the data with the WordPress API
into react so all the display stuff the
UI
everything that he user sees is is react
okay side Siberian well there's more to
the name I'm just gonna say Siberian for
short says off-topic question bootstrap
versus foundation I know I don't really
use bootstrap or foundation often
actually I just help someone out with
one of their projects last night someone
had watched the livestream
yeah I've chat yesterday and I had
mentioned that they could direct message
me to help out so they did and gave me a
link to the project and it was using
foundation and I haven't worked with
foundation for a really long time so
that was kind of cool and interesting
too I just read through the docs a
little bit and I think ended up fixing
the problem I haven't heard back from
them though so hopefully I fix the
problem so that's like the most
experience I've had with foundation a
long time in with bootstrap the last
time I used bootstrap was probably when
I went through like the very first part
of the free code campaign sorry let me
take this call really quick it's just
gonna be a few seconds hello
yes I'm still here are you are you
leaving now okay yeah if you could that
would be awesome
sorry I didn't come over yeah I'll be
I'll hope you hear Thanks all right
right
sorry about that but here's the the time
where I give the usual speech here this
shows about me doing my normal work
every day so interruptions like phone
calls happen and that's okay because I
want people to see what my life as a
front-end developer is so so
interruptions are welcome so anyway
there's a lot of talk in the live chat
about foundation versus bootstrap so I'm
gonna skip over since I am not familiar
that much with either one of them
especially with any like new
developments with them I'm not really
gonna weigh in
Rogerio asks so I need a framework like
that to use react with WordPress er is
it optional so he's talking about do I
need a framework like next j/s which I'm
assuming a framework like next yes
and no you don't really I've used you
could you could use just plain react set
up yourself or any type of scaffolding
that like create react app or you know
anything there's a ton of different
scaffolding options for react so no you
don't really need to next yes just makes
it really easy to pull in data and
render it server-side but it's not
impossible certainly to do it without
next
okay so we did have a couple other like
CSS frameworks mentioned so I'll just
mention them as well XANA mentions
skeleton it's a really light framework
so I haven't checked out skeleton for a
long time but I remember being impressed
with how lightweight it was I'm when I
made it was probably a few years ago
last time I checked it out also I think
there's one other one I saw mentioned Oh
many dot CSS I have I haven't checked so
bill bill says many dot CSS I have no
experience with that but I guess it's a
really bill so it's really lightweight
I just saw that comment that Jack made
earlier about me sounding like Evan
Peters and I still don't know who Evan
Peters is so if anybody knows telling me
please
I'm not really that worried about it but
it would be cool if if I actually do
sound like that person it would be fun
to to listen and compare
I kept looking through again and it
looks like I miss actually two people
said that they think two per row would
make sense for our resources so I am
gonna keep that in mind if you missed I
explained a little more towards the
beginning of the video why I might do
two per row but some reasons why I might
not and it's gonna end up being one of
those things that may happen if I have
time but the way things are going I
don't think I'm gonna have time to do
anything extra to this right now there's
just a lot that needs done before I need
to be done with this project Oh Samson
said I'm late again so I didn't notice
that at first I don't think but what's
alright Samson better late than never
right you can always catch up on the
recording and thanks for joining even if
you know even if it was late that's fine
with me
a los Anna says 11 p.m. it's in if you
don't mind me asking what country are
you in I just like to get a feel for
like timezone so it was about 4 o'clock
here and about 11 p.m. where you were I
said I haven't done this for a long time
but earlier on when I first started
doing the videos I always had everyone
shout out where they were from at the
beginning and it was always cool to see
where everyone was from around the world
so we we definitely have I mean we
started out with like a hundred years
and now we're down to 34 so won't have
quite as many but if you're still
listening and able to it would be cool
to say where you're from and I could
just read out really quickly where
everyone's from I'll have to remember to
say that at the beginning when we have a
lot of viewers for the next one
because that was always really fun and
sometimes people who are maybe too
nervous to ask a question or give a
comment about code are cool with
shouting out where they live because you
know it's a much much less pressure on
them so it's kind of cool because you
know more people join in the chat right
away
vipul said hi hey thanks for joining on
vipul also says what is react and what
is the difference between react and are
so reactive javascript framework and i
actually L reto there's some good
answers in live chat so l BRE so says
it's like react versus angular verse
with you so like there's a distinction
between what react does and what angular
does but like for the most part people
do compare them so reacts if you know
about angular or about view you can
pretty much think of react in a similar
way I know people say that like angular
handles the entire like MVC if you're
doing an MVC like style project and
angular is just the V in MVC or MV star
is what people say sometimes but aside
from that usually people do use one or
the other
angular will react
XANA says tried to learn angular in 2016
but I didn't have solid no js' knowledge
at the time and didn't understand much
but now I can say it's something I could
grasp quite easily but I'm sure react is
better actually
that's like the same experience that I
had so I think it was I think it was
maybe for me like 2015 yeah I mean it
was like 20 2015 possibly early 2016
when I tried to do something with
angular but I had the same problem I
just wasn't good enough with JavaScript
and I just couldn't get anything to work
in angular so but now I'm sure it would
be different and I've heard angular has
changed quite a lot since when I worked
with it it was angular 1 now I think
they're up to 4 and I'm not even sure
but yeah so I don't know enough about
angular now especially the new versions
to really say much about it but I've
seen a lot of cool things built with it
and I know people that have built that
that develop an angular and they're
really good good developers way better
than me
now Bree so says I just learned about
Beaumont CSS I've never heard of that
is it good as anybody used to okay jack
says Evan Peters was on American Horror
Story and he was Quicksilver in the Fox
x-men movie no way maybe the second
first-class movie oh cool I really like
that character I'm gonna have to listen
to him now
I mean like whenever you hear your own
voice like when you're talking it sounds
way different than it really sounds to
everyone else so I'll have to listen to
a recording of my voice and then listen
to that guy too but that's cool I'm
definitely fine with sounding like him
his character and the movie was probably
one of my favorite characters so so I
think that as a compliment
thanks jack alright so you did some
people shouting out where they're from
bill saying I'm not gonna shout out
everybody's names in case you don't want
people to know where you're from I'll
just say where it is so we have Michigan
Texas Chicago London New York another
Chicago Serbia Ontario and Delaware and
says Delaware don't ask cool so we have
definitely like all over the United
States and then some foreign countries
as well
Ireland - awesome actually uh we have in
my department our head videographer
director of videography is is from
Canada so I can't remember if he was I'm
pretty sure he was from around Ontario
as well his family actually still lives
up there so he's trying to like work and
get money to be able to move him down
here so but really good guy very
talented with the video work he does Oh
Romania okay cool
I I just love that there are so many
people from all over all over the world
always my um the people that are like
the head of my department are really in
pretty much everybody that's higher up
here at the University of our work is
pretty much really against remote work
because they say like all you need to
come in so we can collaborate and I
always think it's funny and I usually
make comments like I pretty much stay in
my office and when I need to talk to my
co-workers that you slack and and then I
come on here with you all and we
basically build websites together I mean
so much of the decisions that I make are
based on your input and then at times
you all even write code and submit pull
requests so we work on these sites
together and I feel like I collaborate
with you all even though you're spread
throughout the world then I do with I
would say 99% of the people that
actually work here on campus so so it's
always crazy to me the idea that somehow
I have to be physically present on
campus to be able to collaborate and
that's that's just insane in fact I had
I had two meetings today I will actually
I had three phone meetings today
two of them were phone interviews with
people and I didn't even go in they had
a conference room set up with a
speakerphone and I didn't go in there
because for me that would have been
harder it would been harder for me to
hear I would have had to shout for ever
someone to hear me on the speakerphone
instead I sit at my computer i dial in
through I'm a Google Phi customer so I
just dial in through Gmail it's the same
headphones I have one now I'm using the
same mic that I used to livestream I
have my my setup here with my computer's
so when I'm talking to a candidate I
have their websites up and their resume
and I can check out everything it's so
much easier for me to interact with
people from right here in my office and
then the third meeting that I had I was
actually driving to go get some food
really quickly I decided to go get food
25 minutes for
I've stream started so I went to the
store this I didn't speed but I like
went to the store grab something really
fast bought it and came back and I made
it back with five minutes to spare I was
excited about that but I had a phone
call meeting on the way there
which was fine which I was totally able
to contribute to this meeting while I
was walking around in a store so it's
just I'm a really big advocate of remote
work in case you couldn't tell I think
there are definite advantages to it
there are advantages to being able to
meet face-to-face
- but anymore when you have video chat
and I mean soon virtual reality is going
to be like high enough quality that it's
gonna really mimic you know being next
to a person so at that point the
advantages of being face-to-face are
gonna keep going down and down and I
guess you're just better off meeting
online and not sharing germs at that
point anyway sorry for the long the long
speech occasionally I go into long talks
about my opinion but I actually gain
viewers during that old thing so maybe
it was good so let me I had a couple
more questions while I was talking so
I'm going to go through that and then if
I don't get any other questions that'll
be all for today so Sam says for someone
who has primitive knowledge in HTML CSS
how long does it take an average person
to get to the point where you can apply
for jobs I would say apply for jobs at
any point first of all so that's not
exactly an answer to the question but
people need like a varying skill levels
so like potentially there are a lot of
businesses that think they need a
developer but in reality they have like
a wordpress site that needs just really
basic stuff done they need somebody to
like upload blog
the wordpress and change images and
stuff in that case like you can
definitely get that job you can get
freelance work with just basic knowledge
of HTML and CSS that's how I started out
was just getting freelance and
subcontracting work and then I just I
really worked on my CSS and HTML skills
and once I got more comfortable with
that I I turned to improving my
JavaScript and I started trying to only
take jobs where I would learn what I
wanted to learn if I could sometimes I
just take jobs just for money because I
had to pay the bills but you know all my
side projects and things would be based
around what I wanted to learn the more
you know the more jobs you'd be
qualified for but I would say like at
any point if you find a job that you
really want to do apply you know you
know be honest about what your skills
are but you know you never know and so
much of this is just learning what you
need to learn to get the job done that I
would say there's not really like a
standard time period of how long it
would take it's just entirely dependent
on how much time you have like every day
to put into it what the resources that
you use how quick of a learner you are
there's just too many factors to say for
sure but my only advice is just don't
feel like you're not good enough to
apply for things you know if you if you
meet even some of the requirements for a
job it's worth it to apply unless the
application process is just way too
difficult then then forget it
but if it's an easy process to apply you
may as well do it I mean the worst that
could happen is they say no and you just
move on
I once applied for a job where the
minimum requirements were a master's
degree and they prefer to doctorate and
they wanted like seven years experience
doing a job that I never did and hold on
one second I I gotta get this
okay someone was at my door
but anyway so I applied for this job and
obviously I didn't get it but I did
actually get to like sit face to face
with a person that was interviewing with
the job
it wasn't like really an interview but
it was just the person actually gave me
a bunch of advice on what I would need
to do to get myself ready for a for this
job in the future if it ever came open
again so it was definitely worth the
experience was good and you know it
ended up being worth it for me you know
I was totally not qualified for it but I
got some really good advice from you
know from the person that was hiring for
the job so you never know
dana says do you also review websites
and give tips on improvement I mean like
not officially but I've had a lot of
people since I started live-streaming
just send me messages on Twitter and
with links to their stuff and yeah I've
looked looked at it I've given tips
sometimes like people get err errors
with things and they don't know what's
going on and so I'll actually try to
help them with that you know it just
depends on how busy I am at the time
like if I can get to it it may take me a
little while to get to it but like last
night I was able to figure out something
for someone that watches the stream and
it didn't it didn't take me very long I
was looking at their code on my phone
just like right before I went to bed and
I kind of figure it out so I just opened
my laptop real quick tested it it worked
and just sent a message back and so you
know occasionally I'll just get a few
minutes here and there and I might be
able to help you out so yeah so feel
free I mean if I ever get to the point
where I'm getting like hundreds of
people asking then maybe I'll have to
stop but right now like I'm not really a
big deal right now I only have like 40
people viewing the stream at this point
- I'm definitely open to you know
helping you individually if you want me
to Ken's Ken says me to remote is great
today in in office two days in offices
enough so when we were talking about
remote work yeah I agree I I honestly
think like from my job in particular I
could definitely do most of my job from
home and I could probably be more
productive from home there'd be less
like interruptions I could see like if
they really want me to come in for a
meeting or something then I would come
in for that but otherwise yeah I think
working from home is is great and then
from the perspective of the company like
if an employee works from home they
don't really need an office they maybe
just need somewhere to hang out at when
they have to come in so you save space
or not providing an office then you
don't have to worry about providing the
air conditioning and the electricity for
that office right so you know you can
end up saving a lot of money you know
for the long term by having most of your
workers be remote or at least those who
could be remotely remote so um
definitely it's a good idea Gina asks
what are you using for back-end so this
the the backend for the site well I
guess node it's running on node and then
the content management system is
WordPress and that's running on that
uses PHP and then I mean just to kind of
say the entire stack is the site's
the WordPress site is PHP and it's
running on a with Apache and I believe
it's using nginx as a reverse proxy the
node installations are
I actually have I'm using load balancing
between two digitalocean droplets that
are both running Express which is with
node and they're running react then they
are running behind nginx being used as a
reverse proxy and then in front of all
of that is a digitalocean load balancer
so that there's really like never any
downtime for the site so that might have
been more information than you were
looking for but hopefully it answered
the the question
Umberto's said I'm definitely an
advocate of remote work as well I'm the
telework coordinator at my workplace but
my boss doesn't allow us to telework so
frustrating oh wow yeah that's that's
Thanks yeah you would think you'd be
able to do that from oh well maybe maybe
someday and he gets into it Archer
Archibald says okay in response to so
the question from Sam was about how long
does it take an average person to get to
the point where you can easily apply for
jobs or where you can't apply for jobs
and then Archibald says in reply when
you can comfortably build something that
uses auth user roles databases then I'd
say you've got the skills yeah I mean if
you get to that point you for sure have
the skills I would say you don't even
have to get to that point simply because
I got a full time job doing web
development without even ever doing any
of that stuff so it does depend on what
you're doing like I mean if you're gonna
be a front-end developer you don't even
necessarily have to know that much about
the other stuff especially if you're
gonna get a job at a company where there
are other people handling that kind of
thing like the databases and things you
just have to know how to talk to the
databases you know through api's and
things but but yeah I mean your goal
should be to know how to do that you
know off the user role stated
if you have all that you'll be people
will want you right yeah they'll want
you to work for them if you have all
those skills bill says even if you get
turned down at least you gain some
interview experience yeah exactly
exactly just the experience of it is
it's really important it is it is
important having confidence when you
interview is a really big deal
when I interview somebody and they don't
seem really confident it's just like
even if I can see their code and see
that they can do the job it just really
makes me doubtful if they're not
confident in their interview and you
know there might not be the best judge
of things but you know I don't want
people to be like overconfident but it's
nice you know if you ask someone a
question an interview if they can say
yeah for sure I can do that or I can
learn that you know that's that's
important and I think to get to that
level of confidence in interviewing it
helps that practice
Dana says I'm actually looking to hire
people skilled in react post post I'm
not pissed Postgres QL I never know how
to say that but etc where would I go to
find qualified independent coders I
would like some way to verify their
skills before hiring I guess to defend
like if you want to employ them directly
I'm not exactly sure there there are
some places where that will help you
find candidates trying to think I just
saw a place like that recently where
they handle the testing them like doing
coding tests but I can't remember what
it is I'm sorry if I remember at all
I'll try to let you know but I don't
remember it but then also like if you
wanted to hire developers through like a
middleman company their companies like
top Tao
it's t.o.p tal where you can hire a
developer but you know tops how it
handles all the contract stuff and
payments so it's just I guess it depends
on what you would you need
okay actually well this is really cool
so there are a few people in the live
chat that are responding to danishes
question about being able to hire people
so so that's cool
I don't know yeah Danish if you uh if
you're on Twitter and you want to tweet
you can like mention me and a tweet
about wanting to hire people and I'll
retweet it for you that might help I
mean I have I think I only have like 250
followers or so so it's not like I have
a lot but if like I could potentially
get retweeted some of the people that
follow me have a lot of followers so if
I get retweeted it could get out to a
lot of people so so I guess let let me
know you know send me a tweet if you
want me to do that it's it's worth a
shot
ok bill says that he's seen people use
hacker rank as an initial interview
process actually that's cool I never
thought of using hacker rank that's a
good idea
Oh Sam asks how does WordPress CMS
played with nodejs isn't it a different
stack all together as in a lamp stack
this is the first time I was watching
your livestream I am yet to browse their
previous upto uploads yeah that's cool
lot I mean honestly it would be a really
daunting task for someone to get through
all the live streams at this point
because they end up there's a lot of
them and they're really long so yeah I
don't I don't mind I did explain a lot
of it before but I don't mind at all
giving a little explanation basically
the WordPress installation runs on a
totally different server so it can have
its own stack and then node has its own
stack and they don't you know mess with
each other I have heard of people I've
had people message me on Twitter and
telling me that they've gotten it to run
on one server together so I'm not
exactly sure how to do
but it's possible
I always just run them on different
servers and then it ends up I mean
obviously it just works and then you
just share data from through the
WordPress API is just a REST API so you
just make normal API calls from node to
WordPress no unbuilt bill basically just
said the same thing about the API so
thanks Bill
okay and Berta said dice comm so that's
also another place to find coders so
awesome so I've gotten to the end of the
live chat and well I just looked at the
time it's a long chat all right so
probably won't be doing too much on this
site before the next for the next show
so you won't miss too much we'll
probably be right back where we started
so anyway have a great weekend and thank
you so much for watching and I'll be
back I'll be back Monday I should
probably check my calendar really
quickly just to make sure I will be back
Monday it's possible that I might have a
meeting or something so I have my
calendar up here on another screen so
just take me a second okay yeah I'll be
back Monday it looks like I have a
meeting at 3:00 p.m. on Monday so it
might be a little bit shorter than
normal but I should be back at 2:00 p.m.
Eastern Time on Monday so anyway again
have a great weekend thank you so much
for watching and contributing in the
live chat if you're watching this later
on and you have questions or anything
like don't hesitate ask me on Twitter
ask me in the comments I'll try to get
back to you as soon as I can
and I really appreciate everyone's
contributions today you all are really
awesome so I'll see you see you next
week